Hey wise,
crack jared again and today we're
talking about everyone's favorite anime
with an uncomfortable amount of underage
crotch fondling a curatory,
Aamas enduring and much beloved dragon
ball.
Dragon ball may appear to be little more
than a run of the mill adventure show
for kids.
The series and it's spinoffs actually
have roots in some pretty hefty
philosophical material.
Many fans are aware that in creating the
earliest episodes of Dragon Ball,
Toyama drew inspiration from a 500 year
old Chinese classic journey to the West.
These superficial similarities are easy
to spot.
Both feature a group of four adventurers
in search of powerful magical objects
among them,
a monkey like creature with a magic
staff,
a horny piggish looking fellow,
et cetera.
Often overlooked,
however is the fact that dragon ball,
much like journey to the West can be
read as an explicitly Buddhist allegory.
Indeed a show that many of us watched in
our underwear on Saturday mornings while
wolfing down cookie,
Chris offers a surprising take on
fundamental elements of Buddhist
doctrine.
Welcome his wise crack addition on the
philosophy of dragon ball and note to
the die hard fans keeping score at home.
Since a full discussion of the extended
Dragon Ball universe would take quite a
while.
Today we'll focus mainly on the episodes
of the original animate most heavily
influenced by journey to the west,
the 13 episodes comprising the emperor
loft saga.
But first a quick refresher.
Dragonball follows Goku a young boy with
a monkey tale and superhuman strength
and Bouma a girl who plans to collect
the dragon balls in order to wish for a
new boyfriend.
Along the way,
the team up with oolong a shape shifting
pig and yum cha,
a desert dwelling band that with a
crippling fear of women,
they are in a race against time to
collect all seven dragon balls before
the evil emperor Pilaf can snag them for
himself.
At the last moment when Pilaf has
gathered all the dragon balls and it's
about to wish for world domination,
Oolong saves the day by sabotaging his
wish.
I want to have no world.
The world's most cocky about parallel
track
journey to the west follows trip,
hit tikka a Buddhist monk and his three
disciples,
monkey pigs,
he and sandy on their quest to locate
and bring back sacred Buddhist scrolls
to the Chinese court.
When the pilgrims arrived at the
Buddhist paradise,
the scrolls they received out to be
completely blank.
While journey to the West involves
character searching for a magical
object,
there's more to it than your basic
annoying fetch quests.
The novel is often read as a Buddhist
allegory,
one concerned with spiritual
enlightened.
The characters move from a place of
ignorance to one of insight as they get
closer to their destination.
Surprisingly enough,
the same applies to dragonball.
Both Dragon Ball and journey to the West
have their philosophical grounding.
In Mahayana Buddhism de Vastly
oversimplified the Mayana approach to
Buddhism is distinguished from the
earlier teravata school.
Nice emphasis on the collective
enlightenment of all sentient beings in
the universe rather than that of any one
individual.
Accordingly,
dragon ball puts a premium on acts of
compassion and on the growth of the
group as a when the heroes are dragging
a ball.
Put others first.
They advance in their quest when they
act selfishly and refuse to see things
from other's point of view.
Their progress is delayed.
In the second episode,
Goku and Boma encounter a beach turtle
who explains that he's lost.
I wish there was a way we could help
you.
Hey,
I know.
What do you like me to carry you to the
scene?
Mr Turtle while go,
who wants to put their journey on hold
in order to help the turtle?
Boma wants to get right back to her
quest to find the dragon ball.
We're on an adventure.
We don't have time to transport a beach
turtle.
Okay.
However,
go coups.
Active compassion unexpectedly turns out
to be the most direct route to the next
dragonball.
Enter master Roshi hermit and pervert.
Extraordinary Roshi is grateful to go Ku
for returning the turtle to the sea and
gives Goku his iconic flying Nimbus
cloud as a reward.
You also happens to own a dragon ball,
which he's willing to give the boma and
exchange for.
Well,
it's a weird show guys.
The ethical implications of trading peep
shows for magical jewelry aside.
The fact remains that Boba and Goku find
the dragonball because Goku is willing
to delay his own gratification and rover
to help out a fellow being in need.
So aren't you glad we decided to help
the turtle now it paid off.
I sure am.
You are so right.
You don't have that.
I think about it as the series goes on.
Goku spends a lot of time dragging
around his useless childhood friends
while doing all the world.
Yeah,
I'm looking at you.
Crillon did that ain't compassion.
I'm not sure.
What is this correlation between ethical
behavior and speed of progress is lifted
straight from journey to the West in
which a lack of compassion on part of
the pilgrims causes delays that can only
be resolved through compassion and
understanding.
Monkey often gets in fights with
monsters only to realize that those
monsters were supposed to help him.
Both Peggy and sandy start out his foes
only to eventually become allies.
This goes part of the way toward
explaining early dragon balls,
unexpected attitude toward violence for
a franchise that would eventually go on
to features,
scenes such as this,
this,
and this.
Dragon ball and its earliest episodes as
a surprising lack of violence like
journey to the west.
The show is preoccupied with a
particular Buddhist conception of
nonviolence.
Violence is not universally wrong so
much as it is cumbersome to some degree.
It does get in the way of insight.
Conversely,
compassion facilitates spiritual
progress.
This understanding of violence as
roadblock is most clearly displayed with
the ox cake.
When the group first meets the ox,
King Goku tries to beat him up in order
to clear the pathway of Fire Mountain
and take his dragon ball.
The enormous man barely feels go cruise
attacks for the duration of this fight.
Everyone involved is stuck in an
unproductive,
pointless cycle that gets the pilgrims
nowhere.
It is only when Goku and the ox king
begin to each other's needs through
conversation that the team gets any
closer to their goal.
We are collecting these and I think you
have one.
I think I've seen one in my cousin so of
course you could have it.
My new little friend,
compassion and understanding rather than
violence lead to the trade that
eventually nets the team.
Another dragon ball,
which is all well and good when you're
dealing with a scary but ultimately
harmless threat like the ox king.
But how should our heroes approach a
threat that can't be reasoned with?
According to writer Paul,
our Fleischman,
the Buddhist approach to nonviolence
makes room for this kind of scenario as
he says,
permitting someone else to perpetrate
harm without consequences is not
nonviolence.
Defending innocent lives with violent
means is hardly ideal,
but it's preferable to rigid pacifism.
And the last few episodes of the emperor
p Loft Saga,
the team is confronted with an
existential threat when Goku turns into
a giant ape at the site of the full moon
and threatens to eat boma.
So Yom Chupp wore an oolong cutoff.
Go coos tail to safe Boma and stop Goku
from doing something he'd later regret.
They're limited use of violence prevents
worst violence down the road.
This way at least nobody dies.
This more nuanced understanding of
violence would pop up in Torrey aamas
later work as well.
Listen to go description of himself in
response to freeze his question.
Hello,
how are you?
Hi,
I'm the hope of the universe.
I am the answer to all living things
that cry out for peace.
I am protector of the innocent.
I am the light in the darkness.
I am true nightmare.
Unlike the various villains that maim
and murder throughout the series go Ku
commits violent acts to preserve peace.
Perhaps most interesting is how dragon
ball handles the Buddhist concept of
empties.
The idea that things in themselves,
how no inherent or fixed essence early
on Toyama asks us to consider this
concept in relation to the dragon balls
are these gems have the power to do
great things and not so great from the
start.
The series points out that the dragon
balls are neither inherently good,
bad or anything in between there simply
a store of potential energy use to
fulfill wishes even so the hero's revere
them as a life changing miracles.
Their disposition toward the dragon
balls mirrors the pilgrims attitude
toward the sacred scrolls in journey to
the west.
When the Buddha's assistants actually
give them scrolls that are blank,
they are more than a little pissed off,
but they shouldn't be.
Scholar Andrew,
who we are used at the blankness of the
scrolls,
is a material manifestation of the
Buddhist doctrine of emptiness assigned
pointing to the nature of ultimate
reality.
The Buddha himself explains to the
pilgrims that as a matter of fact,
it is such blank scrolls as these that
are the true scriptures by undercutting
their expectations.
The Buddha provides the pilgrims with a
profound lesson about the nature of
reality,
namely that it's empty of any inherent
essence.
In this way,
the prank actually advances their
spiritual progress.
A similar bait and switch occurs in
dragon ball.
Remember,
oolongs panty wish by ruining pilafs
wish oolong undercuts the hero's
expectations,
turning something as momentous as the
summoning of the eternal dragon into a
joke.
While the dragon balls may have provided
oolong with a pair of Panties,
they haven't changed anyone's life in
any meaningful way,
which is not to say the journey was for
nothing far from it in both the show and
the novel.
The revelation of the quests inherent
emptiness serves as a catalyst for
growth beyond what the characters
expected.
In the final chapters of journey to the
west,
the pilgrims are made into high ranking
members of the Buddhist Paradise while
the heroes of dragon ball gain insight
into the true scope of their various
problems,
which turned out to be not as terrible
or permanent as they thought.
Boma and Yom Cha plan to use the dragon
balls to find a boyfriend and cure
social anxiety respectively.
But after long pulses stunt they realize
the solution to their mutual problem has
been in front of them the whole time.
They agree to get together on the spot.
Bobo lets go of her need for perfection
and Yom sure lets go of his fear.
Even Oolong who we first meet kidnapping
young girls to staff his would be Harem
has learned to find happiness in
thinking about others.
Besides himself.
When asked whether he will accompany Yom
trying boma to the city,
he says,
Oh wow,
I guess I'll go.
You guys need me.
So turtles flashing panties and more.
All in all a pretty weird way of getting
a religious message across.
But that's kind of the point.
My Yana Buddhism with its emphasis on
teaching and collective enlightenment is
big into the concept of skillful means
or the guiding of Cindy and beings
toward enlightenment according to their
current abilities and other words,
meeting people where they're at.
One way to meet people where they're at
is to dispense with the dry lecturing
and tell them a damn good story and this
is exactly what dragon ball and journey
to the west do with engaging plotlines
creative characters and writing that is
alternatively tense and hilarious.
Dragonball successfully weaves Buddhist
morals into a story that people love to
come back to again and again and it's
bad as thanks for watching wise crack
and you can't get enough dragon ball.
There's plenty more where that came
from.
Ap Checkout verb,
that's VRV.
It's made by our friends over at crunchy
roll and they want to give wisecrack
fans seven days of free sweet hd ad free
viewing verb is a mega service,
which means after you get your fill of
dragon ball super on funimation,
you can hop over to crunchy roll for
some attack on Titan,
then dropped by verbs,
select for some harmonquest without ever
leaving the site.
And now the value of the Combo back has
gotten even better with new channels
included like shutter where you can
scratch that horror rich or Alpha for
all your gaming needs and it's still
only nine 99 a month.
So head over to [inaudible] dot co slash
wise crack or click the link in the
description for your free seven day
verve combo pack.
You can get it on your desktop,
on their mobile APP,
Roku,
playstation and xbox.
Thanks to [inaudible] for sponsoring
this video and we've got tons more great
stuff on the way,
including videos on Captain America,
civil war,
Django unchained and South Park season
20 so be sure to head over to our
channel page,
hit that subscribe button and ring that
bell.
Thanks again for watching all your
support.
We couldn't do it without you guys.